I team has learned you may have gone on
stage yes I do we know hooting the
Blowfish I went on tour I ran away from
home there you go and I went on tour I
reckon rolls I'm saying back up sing
another I sang I wouldn't die that
wasn't supposed to be part of it but
this guy the sound guy comes over me on
the side of the stage he goes you've
gone you're going up for only and he
hands me a microphone and I didn't even
know what he was talking about I go sure
and and then I realized only only want
to be with him right
until this song started I have a
microphone I just went up and start
playing the bongos I wasn't invited by
the band today no you were there when
she got oh oh yeah okay oh yeah yeah
they turned around like Darius will be
like he'll hear my voice sounds off damn
country music star lead singer of
putting the Blowfish Darius Rucker away
hey hey Dee oh how are you feeling my
hands are really sore from playing the
bongos I don't play that they are you
don't play the ball goes you fight the
ball okay when did you realize I was
singing on stage oh you know Gary's in
my vocal Gary Gary's in my ear but I
think when you come up they turn it down
I hear so many go Jerry look back back
and there you are
just slap it but you're slapping them
like you hate them and I'm like oh my
god he's gonna break the bongos again
and then you're gonna get banned from
the stage once again did I help her hurt
the show or you always make the show
better okay Derek so Darius has these
earpieces like IFB so he's able to block
out all the noise and I love to just
throw in a little subtle message to
Darius when I'm singing so I got this
microphone and then I'll
just just to mess with him because he
still has to sing the thing and if you
got well you guys have sold out every
place you've gone but if you get an
opportunity to see the Blowfish I mean
it's it's fun it's great now I've never
been on stage at Madison Square Garden
where you guys are going to be Saturday
and Sunday I've never played the garden
is what I'm trying to say if you guys
should I ask for permission or beg for
forgiveness
dude have you ever but you guys have
played the garden before right yeah man
this is yeah we played a few times it's
pretty good still man right the garden
it's pretty cool the garden I know
pretty cool man it's been crazy
I know oh by the way just wanted to know
how your dolphins are going to be if I
said you can start Josh Rosen or Ryan
Fitzpatrick who do you want to say all
right Paul to get your pen out okay oh
no here we tell everybody this Patrick
MVP 42 touchdowns this year 42
you've been are you still drunk yeah it
was a lot of fun and all I'll see you
this weekend in New York okay
hi that's Darius Rucker lead singer
hooting the Blowfish yeah because he he
blocks out all the noise and then he can
hear when everybody's singing and the
guy he was talking about Gary green he
does like the percussion he does bongos
he does a lot of different things
tambourine and Gary had his microphone
and so I'm singing into that and by the
way I only want to be with you that's
not in my vocal range not many songs are
that's not one of my that's not one of
my strong suits there for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]